What we're going to discuss today is how errors propagate in a program,
that is, from one variable to another,
because these very dependencies then help us in reasoning backwards.
And this is our second topic:
how we can trace back these dependencies from an observable failure
to an earlier infection
and then to a defect in the code.
And for this we're going to use the Sherlock Holmes method
which, of course, is: "Elementary, my dear Watson."
But first, a quiz. Do you like Sherlock Holmes?
Here are your options.
Is it more like: "I'm his greatest fan!"
Or: "Isn't he, like, outdated?"
Or: "Actually, I find him annoying."
Or: "Sherlock who?"
Hint: The answer to this quiz will neither determine your grading
nor will it determine the next step. Enjoy.